[Music]
my ridiculous
you like narrating your life you know
there's psychological studies that say
when people are happy they look
desperately for things to make them
unhappy that was Amy and Tony
award-winning actress Christine Baranski
guest starring on the hit show The Big
Bang Theory baranski is best known for
playing Chicago lawyer Diane Lane on The
Good Wife and it's spin-off series on
CBS all access the good fight in this
clip of the season three premiere which
we just saw right the good fight bran
skis character reflects on life while
spending quality time with her husband
Kurt and what was happening in that
episode well you could tell from my line
reading I'm happy that it was a moment
of maybe post-coital bliss and one does
furbished bedroom and her husband
decided to cut back on his work so he
can commit himself to the marriage and
it is a moment when she is perfectly
happy and then what do you think happens
it's all downhill as we were doing a TV
drama that happens to take place in the
current political cultural climate so
how can anyone wake up and say I'm happy
and for that to last for long yeah so
Diane's life gets complicated rather
quickly she finds a little blonde hair
on his jacket and says what's that and
she doesn't ignore it either she's very
interesting yeah who that blonde hair
belongs to yeah I love this this Diane
Lockhart character because you played
her on The Good Wife for so long I
thought how in the world are they gonna
make this work in another iteration but
she seems to be having a really good
time could we describe that about you as
well oh my gosh it's amazing because
they're always for you know seven years
I played Diane Lockhart and she was a
powerful woman who you know ran her own
law firm and she was always in the room
where it happens and she was always with
the guys and and you saw this woman and
I feel like the cultures finally caught
up with Diane Lockhart
there are six women candidates for
president and you have Nancy Pelosi just
saying now just answer the questions and
then we have you saying I'm just going
to sit here to you and it's a great time
to be a woman of any age but certainly a
woman with experience a woman with life
experience education a sense of her
self-confidence and but how are you
feeling Christine because I look at you
you seem to be working harder looking
better no I don't mean that as an insult
because I feel that too about myself I
feel like I look like I think that are
the best time in my life I mean I I
raised two beautiful daughters I know
three grandchildren
I lost my my husband four years ago but
my life is continued in a happy way I am
now number one on the call sheet to my
amazement at my age I find myself the
lead that means Joe yes and and I'm
making more money and I what last year I
did Mamma Mia yes and you know singing
and dancing with Marilyn Sharon looks
pretty good is what you're saying that
that people recognize all of that genius
that you just described or you have you
don't have to push as hard as you would
have 20 years ago like what do you think
the difference is now good question the
great thing is I never maybe because I
didn't consider my beauty or my
prettiness I never was the pretty
leading lady that the aunjanue I never
defined my life by my beauty or my youth
that wasn't my commodity what I had was
you know a level of talent and ambition
and ability to work very hard and I've
just kept doing it so I would say to
young women don't think of you know
don't think of your life in terms of
your youth or how am I going to hold on
to it for dear life don't think of that
as your commodity but what is most
valuable is the cultivation of good work
your character your life experience the
people whose whose relationships you are
comfortable with who are worth knowing
and I have all that in my life know and
I am so I have where's the wood I have a
good
I marvel at this role you didn't even
know what it was going to be no just
said I'll do it without even a pilot no
there's a good reason for that we had
seven happy years of doing The Good Wife
with the great julianna margulies I
carried that show on her back and it was
really about a fault her story and she
was the wife who was you know wronged by
her husband who slept with a hooker and
that brought down his political career
doesn't that sound kind of quaint yeah
anyway less than five second okay but
they conceived of a spin-off for this
character and it's worked out mainly
because I wanted to work for with those
writers so you're a badass christine
baranski